hi guys i'm greg i'm greg greg and creek
i'm john just Kim Jong really great nas
will cover like every [ __ ] movie news
story there is that every once in a
while moving story comes number i'm like
we should talk about this this is
something that sparking a thought here
so david ayer he released the message
talking about suicide squad and weirdly
it gave me hope for his future
involvement in the DC Universe
interesting why let's reveal to quote
first let's take a look at this quote
here he says thank you so much to
whoever asked him something i'm
referring to Suicide Squad I know it's a
controversial film I really tried to
make something different with a look in
a voice of its own I took inspiration
from the insanity original comics making
a movie is a journey not a straight line
I learned so much people want what they
want and everyone has a personal vision
of how each character should look and
walk and talk if you set out to make a
mass appeal movie it's easy to end up
with vanilla but I went for it and I
know soon as that's what has its flaws
how the world knows that nothing hurts
more than a pick up a newspaper see a
couple years of your blood sweat and
tears ripped to shreds the hate game is
strong out there the movie was wildly
successful commercially and the world
got introduced into some very cool
characters in the DC Universe and the
successes do exactly to the Wonder and
power of DC of its characters when I do
a lot of things different yep for sure
wish I had a time machine I'd make Joker
the main villain an engineer or more
grounded story I have to take the good
and the bad and learn from it I love
making movies and I love DC I'm a high
school dropout and used to paint houses
for a living I'm lucky to have the job
that I have I have to give the
characters the stories and plots they
deserved next time real talk and no
there isn't a secret edit of the film
with a bunch of Joker scenes hidden
assault line somewhere kisses David Ayer
for knowing how to acknowledge the
strong criticism the movie received like
he did it in a way that didn't seem like
he was looking for pity or that you know
telling people to shut up or something
like that he did it in a way where he's
like I read the criticism and it was
hurtful sure that sounds someone
I'm working on it at the same time
though it's like he he clearly lets it
be known that he was doing the best he
thought he could do at the time I'm sure
like from his perspective is a lot of
pressures a lot of heat he has to
receive him we chimed in on how much we
hate me too you know so when I heard
he's gonna go up in sirens I was like
why yeah why am I feel like we don't
usually get to here directors talk this
candidly and I think I have a general
more of a general goodwill towards him
even post Suicide Squad than you did at
least initially but but this is actually
I think nice to see like I enjoyed
hearing hearing this it sounds like a
pretty mature sober statement I mean you
know he sounds like I was willing to
learn from his mistakes and to admit his
mistakes and in him cause this is like
Hollywood were like you're in the
business of not admitting mistakes
exists because um good money you know
like it's good to hear it's not placing
blame on anyone either which I
appreciate to like a chemist funky
ladies owning up to the the flaws that
he did feel the film had him like
especially that last paragraph here of
saying wish I had a time machine I make
Joker the main building an engineer more
grounded story like that was the main
thing that you and I felt a lot of
people felt would like why not just make
it a more grounded story where we'll
make sense for the Suicide Squad to have
to fight this person not yet hire people
like boomerang and Harley Quinn to save
the world but make the joke of the mango
would have made for more intriguing were
grounded story sanity happy look like it
was old there it was like it was there
yeah and it's the same yesterday the
good and battler ferment hearing how he
he talked about everything saying he
have to give the characters of stories
and plot they deserve next time it
sounds like he's going to take a much
more thoughtful more personal grounded
approach like he seems like the kind of
guy who's willing to admit to what he
thought he faulted in and go here's how
I'm going to make this better yeah so
while I first heard the news of Gotham
sirens I didn't do a video on it because
I was like I don't want to chime in on
how I'm not looking forward to David
ater doing this reading this made me go
I actually have hope for what he'll do
for the next DC installment that he
participates in it seems like he's going
to be much more aware of what he's going
to be making it sounds like he's going
to know that he has to make it more
grounded and personal rather than try to
go for this crazy high concept
supernatural element
kind of story you know well yeah just
making all the bits and pieces match
because again you know Joker is on the
level whereas you know this is no
characters deserve the story which they
can shine and it's understandable as to
how and why the Suicide Squad just
misses out on that it's like why are
these people doing this so yeah it
almost feels like a wash after that
you're like yeah it's good let's see
them again with a sim you know it just
makes me want to see them in a situation
that they belong in and I feel like he's
sounds like he's geared to give us that
and especially if they give him more
than six weeks to write Gotham sirens or
write the next Suicide Squad I'm willing
to at least open myself up to that I
think he can give us yeah something
really cool and you know him talking
about how he took inspiration from the
original comics and he didn't want to
turn out with something vanilla yes I'm
like well you did succeed in that like
like I always always go bold and study
how engineering I would say like the
film is not generic white house generic
plot points its overall this style of it
isn't definitely not a generic film and
it does have that insanity flair to it
and it so it's far from being bland and
boring which is why I first enjoyed the
theatrical come when I first saw cuz I'm
like I'm just glad it wasn't [ __ ]
dull oh you know yeah I had fun and it
made me feel an array of different than
some very good some very not good but it
was definitely distinct and I had a good
time and that's already more than some
of these movies consent yeah you know so
I feel like this time around oh whatever
he hasn't plans for Gotham sirens or and
I know Suicide Squad to was also
supposed to happen as well I have a lot
more like it wasn't like when I heard
Zack Snyder doing justice league or even
batman be superman for that matter was
like oh my god i really feel like zack
snyder acknowledges anything that was
kind of flawed about his bows you know I
know he did that would be vs I know he
acknowledged some stuff but he I don't
feel like he ever took the true
ownership of it the way the lead yeah
exactly i like the way how david ayer
just in the words even one hears town i
feel like i'm the way phrase everything
out descriptive he was sounds like you
really does realize a lot of these
things and he wants to make sure he does
a great job for the next one he sounds
like a least from this and from some of
the things I've seen around he sounds
like you know
a sharp and thoughtful guy you know at
least at least at his core I think that
he brings a lot of care that have
different i get is I didn't think that
Suicide Squad didn't have care in it
yeah I did feel that way sometimes beam
yes MA and somebody like like David Ayer
I feel like is paying a bit more
attention to the whole after than you
know the next night or light like you
just talked about like I always get the
sense you hasn't he feels a different
way but whenever he addressed his stuff
you know it's just because we kind of
have to but I'm never it never puts me
in a place where I'm like okay I can
expect an improvement next time exact
where's this makes me expect at least
even if not quality improvement at least
you know yeah some new ideas some
adjustments made because he's saying he
has to learn from the good and the bad
yeah so it's not doing like PBS or so
dark a lot of common justice with yeah I
guess the bottom line in conclusion I'm
actually excited for to see what David
Ayer has in store now rooting for this
yeah I'm actually rooting for this guide
I'm not like get him out of there own
I'm actually really looking forward to
seeing what he has to offer for the next
movie he works himself yes if he can
make a great vc movie I would be
thrilled for both him and bc like i
wanted to love these things to work and
you know like a DC films a lot of us are
like I'm not so sure about that like you
know how James one is doing Aquaman
still like the only really huge movie he
did was furious 7 there's like six
installments before yeah just continue
and it kind of make it his own but I
feel like he continued it more than made
it his own and then Aquaman it's like
all right we're going I'm really not
sure what to say about that I'm looking
forward to it but I'm most excited for
the Batman and then whatever david ater
has in store now and thor to authorities
yeah garage that's three rip yeah and
your mains joke after joke what do you
guys think about this message from david
ayer are you excited for Gotham sirens
comments below let me know if you like
hear you but you later you see here you
want to see more and yeah you can
subscribe to the real rejects you on his
reason for Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram and he is the social media
manager facebook.com slash the rejects
and bloom how's your racial media as
well good day to David a good David day
a year